oh my god
you smoke what no
then your face is on fire
it's just the one of going through a
rough patch
what happened the bookmark followed in
your bible and you lost your place
no you run out of room on your fridge
for sheldon's perfect report cards
oh
oh hey um i was just
kidding around i know
why don't you come over here
really and bring the pack
we'll go in the chicken coop where god
can't see us
so george is mad at me and sheldon is
mad at me and
honestly i'm mad at me too
will you please give yourself a break
all that you do for that family i am
surprised you didn't crack years ago
how do you handle it all i'm sitting in
a chicken coop drinking a wine cooler at
11 a.m
clearly i don't
chilly in this college stuff is killing
me i
i never went to college how can i
prepare them
mary if that kid is smart enough to have
colleges wanting him already
he's got to be smart enough to figure it
out maybe
it still hurts to hear him say he wants
to leave
i bet
on the other hand i'm worried my billy
will never be ready to leave
oh of course he will damn
smoking drink in line you're covering
all the sins today
hmm this is terrible i brought you a
snack
thanks
so i don't know if you heard me and your
father having a disagreement last night
a disagreement fine a spat
okay a fight i just want you to know
that you do not need to worry
it's kind of hard not to
sometimes moms and dads have fights but
it doesn't mean that they don't work
things out
did you work it out we're home
eat your cookies
[Music]
mmm